[Music]
foreign
the secret sauce of this movie was
always going to be the ensemble
and to see Rosario Dawson and Danny
DeVito oh my God Owen Wilson Tiffany
haddish Chase Dylan and Blakey Stanfield
together five being off of each other
the chemistry is palpable
we're out working with Rosario it was
the best thank you oh and Wilson Rings a
kind of warmth and a humor to just about
everything he says and does they're
already dead they're gonna be deader
everyone had what their character kind
of specialized in that house has a
string to traumatic events it was one of
those great casts we had lots of fun
it's hard to wrap your head around with
so many incredible talents all in one
project you're just transported
immediately
cool Stone what are you doing out here
we gotta find Toyota
hi Curtis she's everything you think she
is and more for a character so iconic
like Madame Leota you needed somebody
iconic to play her it was thrilling to
work with her I can show you what
happened but it will cost you
three dollars what giant robbery half
box ghost is Jared Leto he put so much
work into the character I can give you
what you want he's the villain of the
piece
I'm not afraid of a couple goals it is a
ride of a movie it's funny it's scary
and exciting if the cameos are wonderful
you're all in for a treat a movie like
this with a cast like this was just a
new experience for me and I loved it
I wouldn't want to be going through this
with anyone else